people will come up to me and say ah if
only I had heard about this five years
ago I wouldn't be divorced right now
radical Candor is caring personally and
challenging directly at the same time
it all starts with soliciting feedback
don't fish it out before you prove you
can take it I like to ask what could I
do or stop doing that would make it
easier to work with me you will give
criticism and you'll learn how to gauge
how what you're saying is landing am I
hearing you say that I can be very micro
managing yeah okay
[Music]
you'll walk away with a toolkit that
will help you navigate even the toughest
conversations with confidence
[Music]